If you thought you knew Claude 3,
scrap that. 4.1 is a whole different
beast. In this video, giving you a
hands-on tour of Claude 4.1 and how you
can use it to level up your writing,
learning, data analysis, coding, content
creation. By the end of this guide,
you'll walk away Claude certified. Let's
dive in. So, what's new? The context
window is massive. It's way better at
coding and troubleshooting. But the real
showstoppers are artifacts, projects,
extended thinking, advanced prompting
tools, next level data analysis,
improved reasoning, and built-in
personalities. These aren't just
buzzwords, they actually change the way
you work. One of the first big upgrades
in Claude is artifacts. And the easiest
way to think of them is as your
interactive workbench inside Claude.
Instead of dumping everything into the
chat as one big block of text, Claude
now creates a side panel where outputs
live on their own. Code, charts,
formatted documents, even little apps,
they all show up in that panel neatly
presented. Creating artifacts in Claude
is super simple. And here's how you
actually do it. Just give Claude a task
that produces something structured like
generate Python code to analyze this
data set or draft a formatted essay. The
moment it generates something that
qualifies as an artifact, you'll see a
little side panel appear on the right.
That's your artifact window. But you
don't always have to wait for Claude to
create an artifact automatically.
There's an artifacts tab in the Claw
interface where you can spin one up
manually. Say you want a blank document,
a code file, or even just a scratch pad
for notes. You click into the artifacts
tab, hit new artifact, and you're
working with a clean canvas right away.
From there, you can paste in your own
code or text or tell Claude what you
wanted to build inside that space. It's
great when you already know you're going
to need a formatted output or want to
keep something separate from the main
chat flow. Using artifacts is simple.
You upload a data set and ask for an
infographic. And instead of giving you
an art or vague instructions, Claude
actually generates HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript. When you hit preview, you
see the chart instantly complete with
colors, layout, and icons. If something
looks off, maybe a circle overlaps some
text, you don't start over. You just
tell Claude what to fix and the artifact
updates in real time. One more preview
and the problem is gone. The best part
is how dynamic this feels. You're not
just reading static code anymore. You
can tweak it, copy it out, download it,
or interact with it directly. And
because Claude now runs code inside its
own sandbox, it doesn't just show you
code. It executes it. Python for data
analysis, HTML and JavaScript for web
apps, whatever you need. In previous
versions of Claude, you had to copy the
code and run it yourself. In 4.1, Claude
runs it, debugs it, and shows you the
output immediately. I can ask it for
something ambitious like a drag and drop
calendar app, and a moment later, I'm
literally dragging tasks around in the
artifact preview window without leaving
the chat. And this isn't only for
coders. If you're working on a long
essay, a research report, or even a
design mockup, Claude can drop the
result into an artifact so you get a
clean formatted preview instead of a
wall of text in the chat. Feels more
like working in design studio than chat
box. Compared to AltClad, the difference
is night and day, like going from
scribbling in notepad to working in
Figma. Once you start using artifacts,
you stop thinking of them as a feature
and start treating them as the natural
place where Claude's finished work
lives. Actually, while we're talking
about organizing your AI workflow, let
me show you something from AI Master
Pro. This is Ask AI Master, our built-in
coach that helps you level up these
exact techniques. See, I could tell you
about artifacts all day, but what you
really need is practice with real
scenarios. So, I'll ask it. What's the
best way to create a data visualization
artifact? And it walks me through the
specific prompt structure, shows me
examples, even suggest follow-up
questions to refine the output. The
beauty is it's not just chat GPT or
clawed with a fancy rapper. It's trained
on our entire knowledge base of AI
techniques. So, it gives you strategies
that actually work. Leo, who runs his
little agency in New York, told us he
cut his content creation time in half,
just using the Ask AIM Master coach to
perfect his prompt structures. This is
the kind of guided learning that turns
theory into real results. Though, no
matter how advanced Claude 4.1 is,
you'll always get the best results when
you communicate clearly. Prompting is an
art, and Claude has some unique quirks
that make advanced prompting really
powerful, especially compared to old
Claude. Let's go through a few
techniques you can use right now. First,
use structure. Claude pays close
attention to formatting. If you wrap
content in pseudo tags like this, it
knows what's instructions and what's
material. For example, summarize the
following article and give me three
takeaways. Text article here
forward/ext.
This extra clarity helps Claude stay
focused and prevents mix-ups. Claude
responds even better to structured
prompts than three did. It's like giving
it a clean template to follow. Second,
assign Claude a role. If you want
professional analysis, start with, "You
are an experienced hiring manager.
Evaluate this resume and portfolio for a
midlevel data analyst role." The
response comes back sharper and more on
point. Or, "If you're practicing French,
tell it to act as a patient language
tutor, and it shifts tone accordingly."
4.1 handles these personas with much
more nuance than three thanks to its
improved style presets. Third, tell it
how to think. For complex problems,
guide the reasoning. Try something like,
"Think through the problem step by step.
Explain your reasoning, then give me the
final answer." Paired with extended
thinking mode. This gives you a
breakdown of the logic and then a
polished conclusion. You see why Claude
decides something, not just the end
result. And if it makes a wrong
assumption, you can step in and redirect
before it finalizes the answer. Fourth,
show examples of what you want. If you
need a report in a certain format, paste
a short sample and then say, "Now create
a new version in this style with the
following data." Claude mimics the
structure closely. And 4.1's larger
context window means it can absorb
examples without getting lost. Fifth,
let Claude refine your prompt. If you
are unsure how to phrase a request,
draft it roughly and then say, "Rewrite
this prompt to be clearer and more
detailed." Claude often generates a
polished version in an artifact which
you can copy and run. It's basically
like having a built-in prompt coach to
help you ask better questions. Finally,
balance clarity with creativity. If you
lock clawed into too many rules, you'll
get rigid answers. If you're too vague,
you'll get fluff. The sweet spot is
clear instructions plus space for
creative freedom. For example, write a
500word blog post about AI and education
in a humorous tone and add one anecdote
to make it engaging that's clear but
flexible and Claude fills in the rest
with flare. When you use these
techniques, you cut down on back and
forth and get outputs much closer to
what you want. Advanced prompting and
Claude isn't about tricking the AI, it's
about collaborating with it. And when
you give it the right guidance, the
results don't just land, they shine. And
I remember like I was drowning in
scattered bookmarks trying to remember
which prompt worked for which task just
jumping between different platforms. So
I created this space where all my best
prompts live in one place. 300 plus
readyto-use templates in AI Master Pro,
plus byite-size lessons that teach you
exactly how to structure these advanced
techniques. What I love is how it
connects the dots. You're not just
collecting random prompts, you're
learning the system behind them. Take
the role assignment technique I just
showed you. Inside AI master pro, I have
templates for automation and efficiency
expert, content creation wizard, even AI
business mentor. Each one is pre-ested
and ready to copy paste. Plus, the
weekly AI digest keeps you current and
techniques like this as they evolve
because let's be honest, prompt and
strategies change fast and having one
place that stays updated beats hunting
for YouTube comments for the latest
trick. Check the link in the description
if you want to see how the whole system
works together. Now, another big change
in Claude 4.1 is projects. If you've
ever gotten lost in a dozen different
chats, constantly re-uploading files and
reexplaining context, this is where your
life gets easier. Projects give you
persistent workspaces. Basically,
folders where your files and contexts
live and every chat inside the workspace
automatically knows them. Yep, similar
to what Chad GPT has. Here's how it
works. You create a project, give it a
name, and load it with the background
materials. you need documents,
spreadsheets, images, notes, whatever is
relevant. Once they're in there, you
don't have to paste or re-upload them
every time. Any chat you open inside
that project already has access. That
means if you're writing a novel, you
make a sci-fi novel project, drop in
your character bios, your outline, maybe
even a map of your world. Then when you
open a thread to brainstorm chapter 1 or
polish dialogue, Claude already
remembers the context. It's like
long-term memory but scoped to one
topic. For real work, this is G. Let's
say I have a project for a client where
I've uploaded their brand guidelines,
all marketing material and analytics
spreadsheets. Now, when I ask draft me a
newsletter with last quarter stats,
Claude posts the actual numbers from the
file in that project without me copying
and pasting. In Claw 3, that context was
gone the second you open the new chat.
Gets better. Projects hook into your
cloud storage. connect Google Drive and
instead of uploading giant docs one by
one, just point claw to them. It treats
those drive files as part of the
project's knowledge. So your AI
assistant now has instant reusable
context across all chats inside the
workspace. So try this. Make a project
for your job hunt. Drop in your resume,
cover letters, and portfolio. And then
just chat. Claude already knows your
background. So when you ask it to draft
a tailored application or prep interview
questions works with that context on
hand. Once you start using projects, you
will see why it's one of the best
workflow features Claude's added saves
you time, repetition, and mental
clutter. If you remember, one of
Claude's biggest drawbacks compared to
Chat GPT is that it can't create images.
And for me, design has always been the
weak spot in my workflow. I can write, I
can sort of code, but the moment I need
to make a poster, I'm lost in Photoshop
menus. That's why instead of trying to
hack design together in Photoshop, we're
relying on chat GBT's image tools. I've
been experimenting with Lav Art Chat
canvas. Chat canvas is basically an
infinite workspace where the AI works
with you like an actual designer. You
click on an element, drop a note, and it
immediately understands what you're
talking about. When I'm working on a
promo poster, I click the title, tell it
make this look retro70s. When I want to
fill an empty space with a rocket, I
sketch a quick placeholder, say add a
cartoon rocket here, and it generates
polished options right inside my layout.
Instead of feeling like I'm fighting
software, it feels like I'm
collaborating with a teammate who just
happens to be a 24/7 graphic designer.
It's quick, it's intuitive, and it makes
design fun. Even for someone like me who
normally dreads it. If you want to see
what I mean, check the link in the
description and try Love Art yourself.
Once you start playing with it, you'll
realize how natural design can feel when
the AI is working with you instead of
just for you. All right, let's talk
about one of my favorite new tricks.
Extended thinking. This is basically
Claude's deep focus switch. Normally,
when you throw it a tough problem like
debugging code, analyzing a messy data
set, or working through logic puzzle,
the quick 5-second answer just isn't
enough. with extended thinking turned
on. Claude slows down, takes its time
and actually shows you its reasoning
step by step. Here's how you use it.
You'll see a toggle under the prompt bar
that says extended thinking. Flip it on
before you hit enter. Once it's on, you
immediately notice the difference.
Instead of spitting out a final answer,
Claude starts narrating its thought
process. It might sketch out pseudo
code, run calculations in an artifact,
or list out options one by one before
picking the best one. If you give it a
data set, you'll see it right. I notice
demand peaks at 5:00 p.m. with 460 rides
compared to a 4 a.m. low, then build
strategies around that. Sometimes it
even pauses to check references it
already knows before continuing. It's
like watching a student show their work
on a math problem. The trade-off is
speed. Extended thinking is deliberately
slower. 30 seconds, a minute, sometimes
more for really complex tasks. And the
output looks different, too. Instead of
polished sentences, you will see raw
notes, thought, verify, data,
consistency, action, running analysis.
You can collapse the log if you don't
want to see the process, but reading it
often helps. You catch where it makes
assumptions, and sometimes you pick up
problemsolving tricks yourself. This is
where Claude 4.1 feels like a huge step
up from claw 3. Before, you only saw the
end result. If it was wrong, you had to
backtrack with follow-up prompts. Now,
you can step in mid-process. If you see
it take a wrong turn in step four, you
can literally say check that assumption
and claude reroutes on the spot. That
kind of transparency saves you time and
confusion. So when should you use it?
Anytime accuracy really matters or the
task is genuinely complex. Debugging
code extended thinking helps Claude
methodically test possible fixes instead
of guessing. Analyzing data goes through
each angle before concluding. Writing a
nuance essay weighs arguments carefully.
On the other hand, if you're asking
what's the capital of France, that's
overkill. It's like using a chainsaw to
cut butter. But when the job calls for
real brain power, extended thinking mode
makes Claude feel less like a chatbot
spitting the first idea and more like a
reasoning partner can actually trust.
Now, Claude has a built-in analysis tool
that works like a code assistant behind
the scenes. The big shift is that you
don't need to jump out to Excel Sheets
or Jupiter notebooks anymore. Claude can
write and run the code for you right
inside the chat and show results
instantly. Here's how you use it. You
drag and drop a CSV straight into the
chat and ask in plain English what you
want. For example, analyze this sales
data. What are the top three products by
revenue? And plot the revenue trend over
the year in a chart. The artifact panel
opens and you literally watch Claude
write Python code, load in the CSV,
group in sales by product, run in the
math, and plot in with Mattplot Lib.
While it works, the chat explains what's
happening. Then the artifact displays
clean, interactive charts, a line graph
showing monthly revenue, and a bar chart
of the top products. The impressive part
is that Claude doesn't just give you
visuals, it interprets them. That kind
of turning raw numbers into a story
where 4.1 feels way ahead of Claude 3.
So whether you're doing basic stats,
digging into trends, or even prototyping
machine learning models, Claude 4.1
works like a personal data scientist.
You don't need to know code. You just
ask and Claude decides when to spin a
Python inside an artifact. It's
basically the future version of
spreadsheets where you say, "AI do that
boring part for me." And it does without
complaint. And if you've ever slogged
through Excel formulas manually, past
you will be very, very jealous. One
thing you'll love in Claude is how
interactive the problem solving feels.
Isn't just question answer anymore. It's
like a live dialogue where Claude
reasons with you, adjusts on the fly,
and stays in lock step as you iterate.
Code in writing or brainstorm in design.
Use it as a code in buddy by asking
Claude to review and run your script
inside an artifact. Paste your Python
invoice script. Say, "Review and run
this and watch it execute on dummy
data." If it hits a bug, say you see key
error, total do claude flags the error,
explains the cause, edits the code, and
shows the success output. You don't have
to say debug this. It just does the loop
for you. Run, catch, fix, rerun. If the
fix isn't ideal, nudge it to try an
alternative approach, swap a library or
refactor a function, and it adapts
without getting flustered. That's real
pair programming energy. Apply the same
rhythm to writing. Have Claude draft
your piece, then target edits
surgically. Say, make the second
paragraph funnier and less formal, and
it changes only that paragraph. Ask for
a touch of humor across the whole email
and a casual sign off, cheers instead of
a stiff closing, and it sprinkles tone
without rewriting your core content.
Because the context window is huge, you
can rapid fire refinements, shorten a
sentence, add an example, flip to active
voice, and it keeps the thread intact
through dozens of turns. Lean on its
parallel thinking when you need
multitasking. Ask, "Summarize this
report and check if any numbers
contradict the spreadsheet I uploaded."
And Claude analyzes both sources under
the hood, merges the results, and
returns a tight summary plus the flag
discrepancies. No second prompt
required. No waiting for step-by-step
handoffs. Treat Claude like
hyperefficient colleague, not a vending
machine. Interrupt freely, steer
mid-process, and correct the moment
something looks off. say, "Uh, wait,
Claude, check that again." And it course
corrects on the spot. With extended
thinking enabled, you'll even see it
stop, reassess the assumption, and rerun
the logic before finalizing. The more
you guide the loop, the closer you get
to exactly what you want, fast, fluid,
and with far less back and forth than
the old way. Last, but definitely not
least, let's talk about Claude's
personality, or rather the one you can
shape it into. Claude 4.1 now includes
built-in assistant personas and custom
tone settings called styles. This is
where Claude shifts from being a one
sizefits all bot to feeling like your
personal assistant. Out of the box,
you've got five preset styles to play
with. Normal, learning, concise,
explanatory, and formal. Normal is the
default friendly helper. Concise trims
responses down to the essentials. Great
when you want summaries without fluff.
Explanatory stretches out teaching with
detail and breaking things down step by
step. Learning is best for students and
explaining new info and formal tightens
everything into professional polished
responses. Perfect for business
communication. You can try this
yourself. Ask Claude the same question
and concise and explanatory and you'll
see the difference immediately. Three
sentences versus three paragraphs. Same
knowledge but totally different flavor.
Where really gets interesting is custom
styles. You create these in two ways.
First, you can describe the tone you
want. For example, write something like,
"Speak with excitement, use encouraging
language, sound like an upbeat mentor,
save it as enthusiastic coach, and
suddenly Claude starts hyping you up
like it's your personal trainer for
ideas." The second way is uploading a
sample of writing. Say you collect a few
blog posts, emails, or reports you've
written and upload them as a reference.
Label it my voice. And when you switch
it on, Claude answers in a way that
mirrors your tone. cheeky, sarcastic,
even echoing your favorite phrases. It
won't be a perfect clone, but it's close
enough that drafts sound like they came
straight from you. For content creation,
that's a gamecher. There's one thing to
keep in mind. The quality of a custom
style depends entirely on the sample you
give it. Large, consistent samples
produce strong, reliable voices. A messy
mix of tones just confuses squad. But
that flexibility is huge if you need one
version for social media and another for
clients. Look, Claude is powerful, but
here's what I learned after testing AI
tools for years. Having scattered
knowledge gets you scattered results.
That's why I put everything I've
discovered, like these prompting
techniques, workflow, strategies, and
tool comparisons into AI Master Pro.
It's not another course you'll never
finish. It's your home base for AI.
Weekly updates keep you current.
Community shares what's actually
working, and tools like Ask AI Master
help you apply this stuff immediately.
Plus, you get discounts on the AI tools
we review, so you're saving money while
you're learning. Search, freelance
writer, and our members said it best.
Instead of feeling behind and AI trends,
I finally feel ahead of them. If you
want to stop chasing the latest AI hype
and start building real AI powered
workflows, check out AMS Pro in the
description and snag 50% your first year
today. Now, go make something awesome
with Claude 4.1. I can't wait to hear
about it. Cheers.